the search is over for the ocean's Gates
submersible that went missing near the
Titanic and there are no survivors
officials say a catastrophic event never
good word catastrophic destroyed the
craft near the wreck of the Titanic
Crews found debris from The Vessel far
out in the North Atlantic in the same
area where the Titanic went down more
than 100 years ago the five victims
include three paying guests a renowned
Titanic expert and the vehicle's owner
Roxanna siberi has been following the
search from Boston throughout the week
Roxanna good morning here we are
here we are Gail this is clearly not the
outcome that anyone was hoping for the
Coast Guard says it's investigating the
debris sites to try to find out how and
when the submersible imploded
there was a catastrophic event the
International Rescue effort now turns to
recovery the debris is consistent with a
catastrophic uh implosion of the vessel
after Crews found five major pieces of
debris from Ocean Gate's Titan
submersible about 1600 feet from the
Titanic shipwreck Thursday this is a
incredibly unforgiving environment down
there a naval official told CBS News the
Navy detected a noise consistent with an
implosion shortly after the Titan First
lost contact on Sunday and that the
banging sounds a Canadian aircraft had
detected on Tuesday and Wednesday were
actually from other ships in the area
ocean Gates shouldn't have been doing
what it was doing I think that's pretty
clear I wish I had been more vocal about
that but I think I was unaware that they
weren't certified
because I wasn't really studying it
James Cameron director of the movie
Titanic and an underwater Explorer has
made more than 30 Dives to the wreckage
site it's not lost on me as somebody who
studied the meaning of Titanic that it's
about
warnings that were ignored
that ships line at the bottom of the
ocean not because of the nature of its
steel or the nature of its compartments
but just because of bad seamanship the
captain was warned there were icebergs
ahead it was a moonless night
and he plowed ahead all five people on
board the Titan are presumed dead it's
unclear if their bodies will ever be
recovered there is a lot that was
learned about the wreck of the Titanic
that was in large part due to pH Matt
tullock knew French naval veteran and
Explorer Paul Henry nargalee for 30
years
how do you think Paul Henry would have
liked to be remembered it was just such
a generous individual and he would like
to be remembered as somebody who
continued the story of Titanic
in a statement Ocean Gate said it is
grieving deeply over this loss the Coast
Guard said while it will continue to
investigate the event it's now starting
to demobilize some of the search efforts
Vlad
a tragic end to this story and still so
many unanswered questions Roxanna thank
you very much